ok si es real si estamos aquí
haz me encanta me encanta estar aquí y
necesito empezar esta plática pero
quiero empezar primero con una pregunta
normalmente yo soy más de escuchar en
este momento sólo puedo hablar pero aún
así quiero hacerles una pregunta y no es
una pregunta si tan retórica y solamente
reflexiva quiero que me la conteste la
pregunta es para qué nos sirven las
historias ustedes creen que nos sirven
no nos sirven son relevantes para
nuestra realidad o son meramente ficción
de hecho me gustaría darte la
oportunidad de que lo comentara si estás
por ejemplo en vivo por el zoom pues
dale comenta lo rápido si estás en
youtube y estás viendo esto en
generaciones futuras
pues ponle pausa al vídeo y date tiempo
de contestar para qué sirven las
historias y en lo que le contestas
déjame plantearte una realidad
alternativa
prácticamente una ficción ok
necesito que cada uno de ustedes
regresen a su pasado a su infancia se
pongan ahí y traten de imaginar
una realidad sin historias y sin
historias me refiero a sin ningún tipo
de narrativa ok ningún tipo de esquema
de ficción y cuentos novelas películas
nada
como se ve tu realidad
imagínate por ejemplo que en vez de que
nos enseñaran sobre moral y ética con
los libros de software las famosas
fábulas pues no se nos hubieran dado
algo un poquito más concreto como este
libro de immanuel kant que se llama
crítica de la razón pura que es lo mismo
pero sin tanto adorno sin tanto
personaje que habla cosas totalmente
irrelevantes o por ejemplo si para
llevarnos a dormir en vez de leer los
cuentos de los cuentos de dormir hasta
lo mejor nos hubieran dado pues esto no
álgebra de baldor porque no digo también
hubiera funcionado nos hubiéramos ido a
dormir un poco más triste espera pues el
punto es cumplir el propósito aunque
bueno por otro lado no tendrías que
estar preocupado en las noches porque el
coco te venga comer si no te duermes
temprano o de entrar precozmente al
sistema de intercambio económico
bebiendo de tus dientes en un ratón que
no sabemos qué uso hace con ellos
hay muchas variantes y muchas
alternativas
bueno no importa lo que piense lo que
piensa esto cómo sería tu realidad sin
historias si la imaginaste una vez
hicimos este ejercicio y alguien dijo
que literalmente vio un recuadro negro
nada
y es que en la verdad pensar en una
realidad sin historia que es casi
inconcebible porque muchas de las cosas
que vivimos que sentimos lo que hemos
aprendido han sido gracias a las
historias todos hemos sido conmovidos
por un cuento por un relato todos hemos
recibido algún valor fundamental en
nuestra vida gracias a una historia
me encantaría que tú me platiques cuál
fue la historia que más impactó a tu
infancia
bueno hay en los comentarios por favor
el título la anécdota como sea que
puedas reflejar esta historia
mientras lo haces déjame contarte qué
historia fue la que más me impactó del
niño y es bien interesante porque no es
precisamente una historia de niños no sé
cómo me dejaron ver esa película a los 8
años pero aún así para mí es un
parteaguas en mi vida y la película es
la del pianista
cuando vi esa película fue la primera
vez que entendí que existe dolor en el
mundo que pude darme cuenta que mi
realidad no era la única y que había
personas que sufrían en otras partes del
mundo hay una escena en particular que
me impactó mucho es donde szpilman el
pianista está refugiado está escondido
en un edificio que es precisamente
ocupado por alemanes tienen la
indicación de no hacer ningún ruido de
ni siquiera salir a conseguir comida
todo lo tienen que sacar del
departamento
y spearman en esta desesperanza ve que
en esa casa en una habitación hay un
piano
y el siguiente la necesidad de ir y
tocar ese piano porque la mala música
pero tú sabes tú como espectador yo como
niño mirando no sabía que fiel ponía una
mano en esa tecla
pues podría significar su muerte porque
si hace algún ruido pues iba a delatar
que él estaba ahí jamás y szpilman llega
se sienta
y decidí a tocar
[Música]
y tú diciendo no por que tocaste porque
te quedaste rata es bueno atraparte van
a descubrir y es una sensación entre por
rojo y belleza porque la música es
hermosa sin duda pero significa que la
van a decir de pronto la cámara hace una
toma así cercana a sus manos y te das
cuenta que szpilman no está tocando el
piano realmente solamente está tocando
solamente está colocando los dedos
arriba de la posición donde van las
teclas y toda la música pasa en su
cabeza para mí eso fue definitivamente
impactante porque también aprendí
que no importa las situaciones de la
adversidad nuestra imaginación nos puede
ayudar a crear mejores
mejores escenarios
y bueno eso es a nivel personal no las
narrativas nos han impactado pero qué
tal qué tal a nivel social a nivel
general y es que la verdad la ficción ha
influido muchísimo más en la realidad de
lo que nos hemos podido imaginar
solamente basta mencionar algunos
nombres del pasado para darnos cuenta de
esto
por ejemplo isaac asimov novelista en
1964 hizo un relato por el 'new york
times' que se llamaba viaje a la feria
del mundo en el 2014 donde
coloca un pequeño fragmento que voy a
leer
qué dice habrán enormes bibliotecas
donde la información será de libre
acceso desde la comodidad de nuestras
computadoras domésticas unos 30 años
antes de que cristian el internet
también él es el creador de las famosas
leyes de la robótica que sentaron una
base para la creación de la inteligencia
artificial y de otras maravillas por
otro lado tenemos al famoso julio verne
que en su libro 20.000 leguas de viaje
submarino' hace la descripción del
nautilus que es este precursor
imaginario de los submarinos de hoy en
día y en otras tecnologías tampoco
podemos dejar de mencionar a star trek
obviamente que es el precursor de la
mayoría de las tecnologías que vemos
tecnologías digitales
en star trek vimos puertas automáticas
teléfonos móviles tabletas e incluso
google glass o videollamadas muchísimo
antes de que se convirtieran en una
realidad parece que el presente ya ha
sido escrito antes porque bueno es
totalmente natural para que algo se
materializa en la vida real primero
tienen que ser imaginado y esta es la
maravilla de las ficciones nos permite
dibujar realidades alternativas lugares
a donde llegar y no se trata tanto de
que sean factibles de que sean
realizables ya no creo que julio verne
se haya puesto a pensar qué tan factible
era hacer un submarino o isaac asimov en
cómo hacerle para crear el internet
se trata más bien del objetivo que ellos
querían empujar en sus ficciones de lo
que ellos querían lograr en sus
historias yo no me había puesto a pensar
en todas estas posibilidades hasta que
un día casi de manera accidental creé
una historia que se replicaría en la
vida real a pequeña escala déjame
contarte cómo fue a mediados de 2016
unos amigos y yo decidimos hacer un
cortometraje nos metimos a un concurso
llamado hazlo en corto que es una
convocatoria nacional que te da un tema
para poder hacer un cortometraje no el
tema de este año fue creatividad y
colaboración ciudadana entonces
decidimos hacer este cortometraje basado
en un guión y escribí llamado el árbol
de la poesía y déjame contarte de qué va
este cortometraje porque es importante
para lo que vamos a hablar
el largo de la poesía va sobre un
escritor frustrado que tratando de
enviar todos los escritos a una
editorial ya diferentes editoriales es
siempre rechazado una y otra vez enojado
y angustiado está en un parque y
finalmente decide abandonar todos sus
escritos en una banca total a nadie le
importa y dejarlos indiferentemente esos
escritos de repente son encontrados por
una chica que los lee que les gustan y
piensa que no es correcto que se queden
solamente guardados ahí así que los
decide poner en el lugar más lógico que
se le dice esta chica que fue un árbol
no sé por qué
pone a los escritos todos los poemas en
este árbol y de repente ese árbol se
empieza a convertir en el centro de
atención
la gente empieza a acercarse empieza a
leer los escritos que están en el árbol
y no sólo eso se empiezan a inspirar y
empiezan a traer sus propios escritos
sus propios poemas sus dibujos pronto
este lugar es conocido como el árbol de
la poesía y te lo voy a dejar ahí no
quiero hacerle spoiler lo puedes ir a
ver el árbol de la poesía lo importante
es que para hacer este cortometraje pues
tuvimos que llevar el árbol de la poesía
a una realidad no de alguna u otra
manera tuvimos que crearlo
pero como no teníamos en nuestras manos
dibujos y cientos de escritos y poemas
decidimos hacer una convocatoria en
facebook e invitar a las personas para
que trajeran sus propios poemas a sus
propios dibujos sus propios escritos de
repente el árbol de la poesía estaba ahí
con escritos de muchas personas y la
gente realmente estaba interesada en ver
lo que había en el árbol muchas personas
que estaban en el parque empezaron a
curiosear a leer lo que había le dijimos
bueno quédense ahí van a ser parte del
cortometraje terminamos de grabar nos
fuimos a editar esta historia mitad
ficción mitad real porque habíamos
diseñado el primer árbol de la poesía
cuál será mi sorpresa al enterarme que
este no sería el primer árbol de la
poesía meses después nos dieron la
noticia de que habíamos ganado el
segundo lugar a nivel nacional el
cortometraje se había publicado se había
visto y la emoción fue enorme pero más
grande fue la emoción al enterarnos que
esta historia había causado un impacto
nos invitaron la ciudad de mexico para
recibir el premio del corto y al mismo
tiempo una universidad nos invitó a
platicar sobre la historia y a proyectar
el cortometraje a compartir con los
alumnos
terminamos esta conferencia regresamos a
donde tenemos que regresar
y días después nos escriben de la
universidad y nos dicen oye sabes los
alumnos han decidido hacer su propio
árbol de la poesía
y es que si tomaron la decisión de poner
sus escritos y empezar a abrirse
meses después semanas después empiezo a
recibir más fotografías de lugares en
veracruz donde un kinder decide también
poner su propio árbol de la poesía en
una primaria y empiezo a darme cuenta
que esta historia se está haciendo
realidad
me pongo a pensar guau yo no yo me
hubiera imaginado que esto se iba a
replicar
pero también reflexionó entonces es
posible no es posible crear ficciones
con el propósito de ser imitadas en la
realidad
de una forma que pueda ser consciente
una forma que pueda ser intencional y
que de alguna manera podamos a través de
estas historias mejorar el mundo en el
que vivimos pero la palabra clave aquí
es consciente porque sin duda la ficción
nos ha dado modelos de vida que no
siempre han sido los mejores ficciones
ciertamente nocivas como nos e
ideologías absolutistas fake news
incluso la sobre intensificación de
ciertos relatos que fingen ser realidad
y aquí es donde nosotros tenemos que
decidir ser conscientes de las ficciones
que aceptamos o que no aceptamos y aquí
está en medio del asunto cuando nosotros
sabemos y reconocemos a una narrativa
como tal o sea como una ficción entonces
nosotros nos podemos convertir en los
narradores de esa misma historia pero si
nosotros no estamos conscientes de que
una ficción es una ficción entonces
puede manipular nuestras vidas y eso
pasa incluso con las ficciones
personales cuantas veces nos hemos
contado historias que no son ciertas de
nosotros que queremos reconocer como
verdad y no como una narrativa que
estamos construyendo el potencial
entonces de las ficciones es entender
que al ser una ficción
nosotros podemos crear los mejores
escenarios posibles pero saben que a
pesar de que esto suene muy bien no es
algo que podamos hacer solos yo no creo
que isaac asimov se haya sentado a
pensar o hubiera podido lograr hacer el
internet él solo que julio verne hubiera
podido diseñar el solo un submarino uno
porque no se trata de eso se trata de
cómo podemos unirnos entre narradores
creadores científicos médicos
estudiantes todas las esferas de la
sociedad para empezar a crear historias
que podamos materializar que podamos
llevar a la realidad esto para mí es la
evolución del storytelling al
storytelling no solamente crear
narrativas que nos hagan sentir que nos
hagan imaginar sin historias
estructuradas que nos puedan llevar de
lo individual a lo colectivo a través de
narraciones positivas donde entendamos
que el punto de mayor conflicto es
también la parte más emocionante porque
lo único que queda es resolver es
encontrar el producto
creemos estas historias diseñadas para
llevarlas a la realidad para poder
empujar sumar ayudar no sé cumplir
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
muchas veces podemos sentir que la
sociedad está carente de este tipo de
historias
y si es verdad pero déjame decirte que
si estas historias faltan es porque tú
no las has escrito
quiere decir que tú tienes la
oportunidad de crear esta nueva ficción
que nos ayude a imaginar mejores
realidades para mí eso significó
renunciar a un trabajo estable para
intentar hacer mi propia agencia de
storytelling logro granada una agencia
que no sólo crea historias que se ven
sin historias que se convierten en
acción y apoyan causas y objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible aún así no creo
que lo tenga todavía resuelto creo que
estar en este escenario ahora con
ustedes es también construirlo y es
invitarte a ti que construyas una
ficción que construyamos direcciones que
nos ayuden a mejorar la realidad una
forma en la que yo lo encontré fue a mis
25 años escribir un pequeño relato en
prosa que me ayudó a mí a dirigir esa
vocación y entender qué es lo que estoy
haciendo hoy así que traje un pequeño
escrito para compartir con ustedes
y es muy personal pero creo que este es
el momento perfecto para abrirlo
se llama quiero ser escritor
quiero ser escritor pensaba con la cara
pegada a la cama la respiración frenada
y en realidad sin pensar en nada pero
como si me leo la gente cree que soy
inteligente por cómo me veo por qué uso
lentes y a veces junto una que otra
palabra coherente en realidad soy malo
redactando en vivo nunca revisó lo que
escribo porque pierde sentido editar las
palabras que salen en vertiente furtivo
cual si fueran fluido carentes de
sofisticado vestido reales crudas y
silvestres aún así quiero ser escritor
cueste lo que cueste lo dudaban darle la
vuelta a la cama a esta altura de la
vida uno ya debiera hacer lo que ama a
sus 25 años mi padre era abogado y no
sólo eso sino oficial mayor del congreso
del estado reciente diputado se asiente
figura renombrada creador de leyes
magistrales que formaban un nuevo
territorio autorizado mucho lo aprendí
de sus manos el fervor que tuvo para
luchar para instalar la primera oficina
de derechos humanos
el ahora descansa pero sus relatos e
historias a mí me dan esperanza por eso
por primera vez pensaba quiero ser
escritor después de todos estos años dos
carreras cursadas empleos formales
trabajos variados y uno que otro
diplomado todo para darme cuenta que ser
escritor era lo único que había deseado
así que las reflexiones diurnas muy
cerca de la costa que traen la marea muy
decidido me di a la tarea de explicarle
para aquel que no crea que no quiero ser
un escritor cualquiera no quiero ser un
escritor de los que escriben palabras
sino de los que la siguen quiero hacer
de esos escritores que les dan formas a
las letras hasta que viven que se
vuelven chispas de movimientos sociales
que se vuelven para los incrédulos
manuales que le dan la habilidad de
soñar en universos laterales
quiero ser escritor que escriba incluso
con líneas gráficas que exprese
historias en las artes cinematográficas
que escribe incluso con el silencio y el
vacío con la música constante que trae
el frío que delirio que las palabras se
vuelvan acciones se vuelvan motores de
nuevas organizaciones que recauden
donaciones que despiertan conciencias
que le rentan tributo a las artes y las
ciencias
creo en eso no tanto en los libros que
cada uno descubre con las letras la
razón por la que vivimos que cada uno
decide por convicción la cual nace de
movimientos que vienen de argumentos que
la mente buscan que abras que provienen
de conciencias que expresaron todo
primero con palabras
la palabra es el inicio de todo lo único
que ha de importarme que incluso en el
relato religioso el verbo se hizo carne
y las palabras se hacen vida se hacen
acción están ahí dispuestas para que el
que la reciba quiero ser escritor no el
que escribe palabras sino el que la
sigue para ver a dónde me llevan para
saber hasta dónde llegan y quién por
ellas revive
voy a ser escritor
y con eso
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]